[Music]
[Applause]
Jason Garrett will be on the call
college football Notre Dame in USC
Saturday night coverage begins at 7
Eastern on NBC and peacock also you can
see Jason on football night in America 7
Eastern on NBC and peacock ahead of the
Giants against the bills what do you see
in Caleb Williams right
now wow what a player uh you know one of
those guys that you start to see on TV
and you're like who is this guy and um
you know the more you study him he has
everything you're looking for in a
quarterback you know I've always said
this Dan that the number one trait for a
quarterback is Instinct feel aptitude
for the game and uh all the great ones
have that and then they have varying
degrees of ability they can run they can
throw they have they have this Talent
level but uh instinct is first feel is
first and he's got that and then he has
all the rest of it too and he clearly
has a Poise and a composure and a
confidence about him that pervades that
whole team he's something else Drake
May uh have you had a chance to look at
him haven't haven't studied him but I've
kind of seen him the same way um you
know Ju Just by TV I haven't done a deep
dive into watching his film but uh
equally impressive guy but if you're
looking at because we're we're trying to
categorize Brock pie now people don't
know is Brock pie good is he great is he
how did everybody miss on him you know
he's the next Montana so so what is it
that Brock py has that maybe uh we we
don't know how to define I go back to
what I said before Instinct feel for the
game and what does that entail for a
quarterback your ability to see things
feel things process things quickly and
and for him to be able to do that as a
rookie to win all these games that he's
won and and and we talked about it the
other night on football night there's no
doubt it's it's an incredibly uh
favorable environment for a quarterback
to play in San Francisco they play great
defense uh they can run the ball they
have weapons all around them it's a
fantastic system Kyle's a great play
caller all of that but you know Kyle
Shanahan's record as as a head coach in
the NFL he's won 74% of his games when
Jimmy Garoppolo and Brock cier is his
quarterback he's won 24% of the games
when those guys aren't his quarterback
so this idea that we it's a great system
we can plug anybody in there I just
don't buy it the the player matters and
I just think he has so many of those
traits we're talking about the Instinct
the feel the vision the processing and
he's probably underappreciated
physically he's a better athlete than
people think he throws it better than
people think uh he just does all the
things that that the Great quarterb
backs do now the package isn't
overwhelming he doesn't walk in the room
64 220 you know uh rocket arm all of
that stuff but he has the most important
stuff yeah but Montana didn't walk into
the room that way either exactly right
and that's why it was a third round pick
and people were like H you know pick 199
in 2000 was the same way right it it's
it's all that it's all that same stuff
so you know the the the question is okay
those are intangible qualities and one
of the things that we used to always
talk about was I get they're intangibles
but there's evidence of intangibles in
all players you know so what's the
evidence of the intangible the Mike
linebacker who the coach says loves
football but doesn't run to the ball you
say well he might like the idea of
football but he doesn't love football
the evidence is to the contrary right so
when you look at a guy like this you say
Okay Iowa State what did he do there
played for a long time was pretty
productive you know everything he did
was was positive and so when you start
looking for it more and asking the right
questions maybe it unearths it but still
the eye test for a lot of Scouts and
evaluators comes first and uh you know
particularly that position so that's why
a guy like this gets Overlook but it's
fun to see him do so well that's what's
you know the beauty of that position is
all shapes and sizes all ages you know
be successful early uh maybe not so late
uh some you know it catches on a little
bit later on I still go back to with
Brock py I don't know how you you define
clutch like how do I see clutch in a
player okay it's college but when the
game is on the line in the NFL and jobs
are on the line and you have to have
that clutch Gene there has to be
something in there with your EKG like
all of a sudden you're like all right
I'm good we're good with this yeah that
that's it and I think you said it's the
low blood pressure thing and someone who
who who quietly Embraces those moments H
he doesn't get all out of whack he he
just kind of is himself and I used to
always say this about Tiger Woods
certainly Tiger Woods made miraculous
golf shots that we all Admire from afar
but when he was going he was middle of
the Fairway middle of the green two Putt
in all the big moments right and then
you know he had the chip out and Masters
I I get all that he was able to do that
that stuff but you know those guys who
are the best do what they supposed to do
they're the best they're the best
version of themselves if you will in
those moments uh it's not too big for
them and certainly he has that Gene
talking to Jason Garrett he'll be on the
call USC at Notre Dame coming up on
Saturday night also part of football
night in America on Sunday ahead of the
Giants and the bills we've talked a
little bit about David teer the owner
the Carolina Panthers and it's an Open
Secret that he's involved maybe a little
overly involved he wanted Bryce young as
his quarterback Frank Wright came out
yesterday and sort of hinted at maybe
not being on the same page but uh what's
it like to be the coach of an owner who
gets too involved in a
situation you know Dan I think
leadership is is is really uh I think
it's the most important thing in any
successful organization and and and
there are different levels of leadership
obviously the guy who owns the team is
the leader right but but there there are
other leaders in the organization as
well the general manager the head coach
coordinators certain players all of that
I always thought a big part of
leadership was okay you're leading down
if you will if you're the head coach
you're leading to your staff to the
players all of that but you also have to
lead
upwards uh you have to be able to create
a vision for the decision maker
ultimately the owner is the decision
maker uh to say okay this is the kind of
team I want to build these are the kind
of guys I want to bring with me to to to
make this Vision that I have come alive
and you have to be very compelling
making those arguments they have to be
consistent they have to be thorough
there has to be evidence so this idea
that okay we're only leading downward
when you're in an organization any
organization you have to lead that way
too because you're not writing the
checks that other guy is so when we were
at our best in Dallas like all
organizations we were on the same page I
made compelling Arguments for the vision
we want for the team we we made the
decisions that followed that we all got
on the same page and and we went forward
that's not to say I was always right
you're listening to the other people and
you're creating this Vision together and
you're making sure we're all aligned the
biggest issue in the NFL is when there's
not
alignment among all the different parts
of the organization this guy thinks this
this guy thinks this we're going to go
his way this time your way and then you
get this hodg podge of an organization
when you get everybody together that's
when you have a chance and so you have
to do that with owners you have to say
okay I get it this is what we're trying
to create and this is how this decision
fits into that vision and if you do that
well and consistently you have a chance
set the record straight on draft night
with Johnny
Manzel
um the big overarching story is we
wanted to go
defense and the guys that we were
targeting uh were defensive players
Aaron Donald being one of them Ryan
shazir being one of them um trying to
think who the other one was the
linebacker from from UCLA who went to
the Vikings Kendricks no uh the bigger
guy damn um not Anthony Bar Anthony Bar
okay Anthony bar so those are the guys
we're targeting we had we had to get
better on defense so I think bar goes 11
Aaron Donal goes 13 shazir goes 14 it's
like boom boom boom you know oh get the
you know that kind of a thing and uh and
so the big blinking light on our board
was Zach Martin Zack Martin is up there
highest graded guy we love him to death
we're still not there with our offensive
line H but we have taken Tyron Smith and
Travis Frederick and two out of the
previous three years so we're getting
there to me that's the key to to
building our team it's why Philadelphia
and is so successful they got really
good linemen and their skill comes alive
so we were making that argument but we
felt like if we can get some of these
defensive guys we gotta play defense too
so when those guys go off the board Zack
Martin's sitting there um but you know
Jerry Jones rightfully so values the
quarterback and he felt like we had Tony
Romo at the time and and getting a guy
like Johnny Manzel could be someone who
uh could provide that
transition you know the great
organizations like green GRE Bay went
from Favre to Aaron Rogers and you know
you want to make sure you have a
succession plan if you will but did he
ask the room what do you think of Johnny
Manzo we had a lot of great discussions
that night no no no no did he have did
he openly say you don't work for Jerry
anymore did he openly say what do you
guys think of Johnny Manel oh absolutely
okay what was your
response I think we should take Zach
Martin just like that yeah no oh yeah no
doubt and that was the consensus in the
room but Jerry wanted Johnny Manzel he
certainly was enamored with the with
having a quarterback wow transition wow
and and so and he'd be the first to tell
you he's he's glad it it went the way
that it did I mean Zach's been in nine
Pro bowls he's going to be a Hall of
Famer he's one of the great players ever
to play for the Cowboys yeah so it
worked out well starting a rookie
quarterback is tricky we've seen CJ
strout he looks pretty good Bryce young
I'm not quite sure uh and then Anthony
Richardson's been banged up we haven't
seen will Levis yet but your thoughts on
starting a rookie quarterback in today's
NFL well you know we started Dak
Prescott you know he was a fourth round
pick for us and Tony Romo got hurt in
the third preseason game and we didn't
have intentions to start Dak we we felt
like he could be the next quarterback of
the Cowboys but you know when Tony got
hurt and Kell Moore was our backup both
those guys go down and all of a sudden
Dak is playing and you know he ends up
we lose the first game we wi 11 in a row
we end up going 13 and three so
um it's not easy to
do uh you have to create an environment
for the guy to be successful we had a
good team we had good lineman we had a
good runner we had a good defense and
and Dak went in and did what he what he
needed to do he wasn't just a system guy
he made a ton of plays for us and really
was made a very positive difference for
us that year uh but I think that's the
exception Ben rothberger started as a
rookie on a really good team uh Dan
Marino started as a rookie on a team
that had gone to the Super Bowl the year
before sometimes what happens uh now is
that everybody wants it right now and
and hey we drafted them play them and
it's hard to do the environment better
be right uh I always think about Troy
Aman you know 0 and 11 as a rookie pton
Manning breaks the interception record
as a rookie I mean these are the alltime
great players to ever play in the NFL
John Elway lining up under the guard as
a rookie you know all of those those
things that happen Aaron Rogers doesn't
play until year four so this idea that
hey play him put him in right now and oh
by the way he's got to be really good I
think our standard gets a little out of
whack even though there are these
exceptions like Prescott and others um
you know it's it's a challenge I think
the Bryce young transition is the norm
when they get better around him you'll
start seeing the Bryce young that we saw
at Alabama um CJ stj Stout has been good
for a bad team well a team that was in
position to be able to take him so high
in the draft he yeah he's been fantastic
and and and it's been really impressive
uh what he's done and and again I don't
think that's the norm and and and I do
think for me the what Tom BR Tom has
impacted the game in so many ways
impacted lives so many ways coaches
players all of that one of the things
that I think he's done that's been
amazing is he plays till he's 45 Drew
Brees plays into his 40s Philip Rivers
Aaron Rodgers all these guys playing as
long as they've
played the runway for a quarterback is
longer now so this idea that we got to
play him now put him in he better be
good or discard him I I don't think
that's the the right way to think about
it and if you do think about it that way
I love what San Francisco did let's go
get Sam darnold he's been in two bad
situations he's still a young guy
hopefully he's not beaten up too much
mentally there's something here and and
he can play for a while it's not like
the running back you know career in into
his mid to late 20s he's done these guys
are playing to their late 30s so
allowing for their growth over time I I
think it's something that that needs
consideration and I think the smart
people are doing that yeah I think
that's a great Point uh but you have
coaches whose jobs hang in the balance
and they don't get that long Runway like
quarterbacks do that they they need that
guy to come in and help because we were
bad the previous year and there there
are coaches who very famously at times
go into an organization and say I
recognize this I'm not going to let this
whole organization hinge on the play of
a rookie quarterback we're going to go
get a veteran and play him we might not
even draft the quarterback we're going
to get better on our team because that's
what's going to allow me the time to
build this the way I want to others say
you get a chance to draft the guy let's
build the whole thing around him so it's
a different approach you better be right
you better be right good stuff Jason
have fun this week and you'll be busy
and uh we appreciate when when I come on
usually will ferals on what happened I
mean don't do this
together that was pretty good will there
with us in Dublin was fantastic yeah not
bad not bad uh thank you Jay always
great seeing you that's Jason Garrett
he'll be on football night in America on
Sunday he'll be on the call with Notre
Dame hosting USC on Saturday night